really penises and vaginas don't have
calories in oh I am erica Campbell I'm a
singer a songwriter a radio host and mom
first lady of a church and all-around
cool chick why doesn't the church talk
about sex I think that people have
associated that level of pleasure with
something sinful and I don't think that
was God's design I think that it was one
of the most beautiful things that he
created and I think in an effort to stop
people from doing it they just didn't
talk about it they bred a culture of
young people who have had to search
other sources and talk to other people
I'm excited and nervous about this
conversation
I mean I've wanted this actually this
specific topic for a long time I think a
lot of people are wondering and their
questions and I'm gonna do the best that
I can the knowledge that I have the
questions the job okay I knew this
question was coming is sex before
marriage a sin according to the Word of
God yes the Bible says marriage is
honorable and the bed is undefiled
meaning once you're married you can live
your life do what you like as much as
you like there's so many other things
that go along with the befores and the
after is why you chose to say yes why
does this person deserve a piece of your
body why how do you look at your body as
your body a temple is this special and
in order to enter this temple what is
the requirement what do you say about
yourself I understand you know I listen
I remember being a teenage girl
wondering I remember before I got
married even wondering and I would love
to you know imply that I waited until I
was married to have sex but I did not
and so you go into relationships with
your ignorant and with as much as you
know as much as you gain from your
friends and nowadays from Google does
sex count as exercise kinda you can burn
the calories right but if you ate 1240
you had sex then you just you still fat
god bless you I love you but you still
be you know thinking the way it's cute
in a vase still thinking aways though
does not sound it
I don't think you can get the body that
you're looking for you can't screw your
body you can't screw your way to get
them looking for is sex a healthy coping
mechanism no because whatever your
coping with after you have sex is still
there the problem will still be there
after you get out of the bed or wherever
they should do what you do but I think
you should deal with the issues
sometimes before you get there before
you get to that place so the enjoyment
the beauty of it is fully there I think
you cheat yourself when your soul isn't
just a little bit connected something
otherworldly when yeah when your souls
are connected have I talked to my kids
about sex well my 14 year old absolutely
because Krista came home and I was
asking her some questions and she said
that there were kids talking about oral
sex in the fifth grade fifth grade well
instead of her getting information from
her friends I trying to seek it out
through music and watching a movie and
trying to put two and two together on
her own I just talked to her about it of
course she was grossed out mom I said if
you and your little girl friends talking
about it y'all know what y'all talk
about I know what I'm talking on you
want to talk to your mama plus I want
you to have a wonderful relationship I
would love to know that you marry a guy
and you have a healthy sex life she's
like I said you'll be fine with this
when you're 20 it's weird at 14 but
guess what I'm gonna talk to you now so
someone else doesn't get in your head
and then you get twisted I want you to
understand your body understanding nasty
Lavoie and understand their intentions
and understand your power and who you
are and who has a right to your temple
because that's what it is you got a
temple girl protecting the sex in
periods cause pregnancy listen is
watching your period is over before you
have sex and if you accidents you
probably don't want to get pregnant so
you're probably too young and trying
don't want to tell your mom okay I
became a mama just now um question is
sex
a necessity no not for everyone some
people live full and complete lives you
know and they feel complete and
fulfilled in other areas of their life I
really think people put way too much
weight on sex what it means about
me what it says about Who I am the
quality of my life because of it I think
that there are people were perfectly
fine without having it I am NOT one of
those persons but there are some some
for faith reasons some for different
reasons but I think that I don't think
that it is a necessity just sex in a car
leaves smell ill nasty yes do you have
booty juice on your car seats oh my god
don't do it people you've all been
around that friend and gotten that
crying is like girl what was you doing
out of control
yeah it does yes it does leave a smell
so don't do it
your mama's car your daddy's car not a
good road you are is sex good for your
health
absolutely I think so I just think
there's you know there's there's got to
be these chemicals or something released
in your body [ __ ]
take you to places nothing else and take
you I'm not a doctor so I can't like
literally sweet to that as a doctor but
I do believe that there's something
quite healthy for every relationship
when you have a healthy sex life it's
sex a decongestant like will it clear
your sinuses
it ain't medicine precious no you know
I'm not surprised by any of these
questions I mean there's so many people
searching and you know we're asking sex
questions but we're really looking for
connection and value and validation and
love you know and sometimes we're
looking for it in the wrong places we're
looking for it to fill spaces and places
that is work though we have to do as
individuals I love that we are asking
these questions I love that I as a woman
of faith you know who loves God and
trust the Creator can't answer these
questions or at least bring light to the
fact that some of us are actually
talking about it always think of them
from a god perspective well I mean God
is not this knee horror I don't want you
to enjoy yourself I mean there's a
scripture says that I want you to
prosper and be in good health even as
your soul prospers so in addition to
your soul and your regular life he wants
you to be happy and fulfilled I know
that's not a message here all the time
but it's absolutely true I'm a living
witness of it and so I want to share
that with you
[Music]
you